so i i know you can't tell but you're
looking at a new and improved version of
me today because i just finished the
canadian government's online ethics
course and so
my my capacity to manifest
ethical behavior has been improved by an
immeasurable amount
so
okay so today we're going to talk about
something that's actually quite
controversial although i guess what we
talked about last lecture was rather
controversial too
people hate this topic generally
speaking
and it's because like there's nothing
ever
there's never any guarantee that if you
investigate things from a scientific
perspective that you're going to learn
things that you want to learn
or that you're happy about knowing or
that you wish were that way
i mean i would say one of the big
advantages to the scientific method is
that
it presents you with data that you don't
like
i mean most of the time when you learn
something it's because you're
running into something that you don't
like or don't want right
because otherwise when the world is
unfolding in front of you exactly as you
predict and hope
there's nothing to learn you almost
always run into an impediment of one
form or another before you ever learn
anything
so we're going to talk about openness
today now that sounds rather
innocuous in and of itself but the
problem is
is that openness is the place in the big
five where iq hides
especially non-verbal iq
which is most specifically associated
with fluid iq
now the thing about intelligence is that
it's not like the big five it's
unidimensional in most regards
so you know if you do the proper factor
analysis with the
entire corpus of trait descriptors in
language you end up with five dimensions
there's no
superordinate single dimension you can
make a case for plasticity and stability
but
the actual utility of that higher order
factor structure
has yet to be demonstrated
in in a multiplicity of situations we
have some evidence
for with regards to plastility and
stability that
plasticity is predicted more by what
people do
and stability is much more predicted by
what people don't do
now i don't know how useful that is i
mean it's kind of an interesting fact it
was an incredibly powerful effect
but and plasticity seems to be
associated more with exploratory
behavior and
perhaps with dopaminergic function and
stability perhaps more with the control
and constraint of behavior and
serotonergic function but it's still
pretty vague so
you can certainly make a case for the
for the hierarchy of factor structure
with regards to trades to sort of top
out at the
five factor level with some possibility
of it of an informative level above that
iq isn't like that it's pretty damn
unidimensional
and it's complicated because
there does seem to be some utility in in
distinguishing between
verbal and non-verbal intelligence or
fluid and crystallized intelligence
depending on how you look at it and i
think the distinction is basically this
is that fluid intelligence roughly
is a measure of how rapidly you can
learn things
and then crystallized intelligence
roughly is an indication of how much
you've learned
and then you can see why those two
things would be very highly correlated
right because
how much you know is obviously going to
be a function of how fast you can learn
but you could also see that there would
be some circumstances under which those
two things could be dissociated so one
of the things that happens for example
as you get older your fluid iq drops
quite precipitously and it starts
doing that somewhere in your mid-20s so
there's
some of you are already getting stupider
which is kind of annoying
at least from the perspective of the
ability to learn but your crystallized
iq or your verbal iq depending on how
you look at it can you
continue to rise for the rest of your
life as you put more information into
yourself so to speak and
some of that might be a measurement
artifact
somewhat because the way that you test
verbal or crystallized intelligence
generally is by asking people
about their knowledge of something maybe
it's their vocabulary for example which
is an excellent measure of
verbal intelligence as you might expect
probably because it's an index of how
much people read
that would be my guess or general
information tests
which is what a sample of your required
factual knowledge and so forth
um that sort of thing can increase as
you
as you age as your ability to learn
decreases
the best way by the way if you want to
keep your intelligence intact
the best way to do that is to uh to
exercise
just so you know it both
weight lifting and
cardiovascular exercise can
maintain your fluid intelligence to
quite a remarkable degree across the
course of your life and the reason for
that likely is that your brain is a
pretty vascularized organ and it use
uses a tremendous amount of your body's
oxygen and energy and so
if your cardiovascular system isn't in
that good of shape then what seems to
happen is that it's harder for your
brain to
get rid of waste products that are
produced during its
during its metabolic processes and so
you can't
work as efficiently there's not a lot of
evidence that
brain games of one form or another can
produce any
real positive effect although there's
scattered reports in the literature that
video games can improve
that can improve spatial intelligence
which is a subset of intelligence even
though it's very highly correlated with
fluid
intelligence in domains other than the
game usually what happens if you
if you get people to develop expertise
at a game that requires abstract ability
like a video game what happens is they
get tremendously better at the thing
that they're practicing but
there doesn't seem to be a lot of
transfer of ability
to different games and and what fluid
intelligence is in large part is
what's common across multiple the
ability that's common across multiple
complex tasks whatever that ability
happens to be
now we don't know exactly what that
ability is
partly because we don't really know very
much about how the brain works but we
definitely know how to measure it and
that irritates people
so iq fits under openness and the
terminology is still a little bit
i would say awkward um
for a while when people were trying to
sort out what the fifth factor was the
openness factor
some people thought about it as
intellect
and some people thought about it as
openness and it ended up being named
openness
when we did our aspects study back in
we broke it up into openness to
experience
proper and intellect so those seem to be
aspects of the higher order
trait and the aspect level
differentiation actually turned out to
be rel
rather useful at least at least so far
so one of the things we just published a
study for example showing that
if you were higher in openness to
experience the aspect you were more
likely to be in the humanities and if
you were higher in intellect you were
more likely to be in the sciences for
example
so anyways what we'll do first is we're
going to talk a little bit about
intelligence per se and then we'll talk
about the trait
the reason i want to talk about iq
really because really that's what i'm
talking about is because
the best measure of the intellect aspect
isn't a big five personality
questionnaire it's actually an iq test
and so and it's very very important to
understand iq and there's a bunch of
reasons for this and
first reason is is that iq is more
powerfully
predictive of long-term life success
than any other phenomena that can be
measured among human beings
and not only that
the statistics that were derived
statistics that were used to
derive iq tests and then used to predict
future performance are exactly the same
statistics that every social scientist
particularly psychologists
every social scientist uses to do all of
their statistics
so you can't criticize the derivation of
iq tests on statistical grounds without
criticizing
every single finding in psychology
that's ever been made by anyone ever
since we started to use statistics
and i would say not only that the best
statisticians
that psychology has ever produced are
the people who invented and promoted and
developed and
tested iq tests so there's no getting
out of it by saying that there's
something
something faulty about the statistics so
for example
stephen j gould who's a famous
evolutionary biologist and
pretty radical left-wing thinker he
debated he had a public debate at one
point about
what he called the mismeasure of man
because he wasn't very much of a fan of
iq tests and
he claimed that iq tests were faulty
because they relied on factor analysis
and
because basically what iq is is the
first factor that you
draw out of a huge battery of
questions that require abstraction any
kinds of questions you'll find that
if people do well on one question they
tend to do well at all the other
questions
that's the general factor and he said
well that's just a factor and that's
means it's a mathematical abstraction
and that means that it's not
real it's like well first of all the
first
factor that you derive out of the
performance indices
for a very large number of answers to
abstract questions is almost
perfectly correlated with the average
the mean
and so that's tantamount to saying that
the mean is a
mathematical abstraction and therefore
doesn't really exist and
well then you have a problem which is
well exactly what do you mean by
exist because you can certainly make a
case that mathematical abstractions are
more real than the thing that they're
abstracted from
if that wasn't the case then mathematics
wouldn't be so powerful
so basically gould's argument boiled
down to the idea that there's no such
thing as an average
well this is part of what makes me a
pragmatist philosophically
i mean there's such thing as an average
in so far as calculating the average and
then using it produces certain
results that you desire in order to deal
with the world
right so the average of a group of
numbers is a tool of some sort
it you know which obviously doesn't
contain all the information that the
entire set of numbers
contained you need at least a standard
deviation to get that as well because
that talks to you about the
the range know the variability but the
idea that the average isn't a real thing
is
you know is silly it's a it's a shallow
criticism
it's also based on complete lack of
knowledge about exactly what factor
analysis does and doesn't do
so now
here's a list of some intercorrelations
here between
the various facets or the various
aspects just so you know how tightly
associated they are so
industrious and industriousness and
orderliness are correlated at about 0.4
that's from conscientiousness volatility
and emotional still stability at about
0.59
politeness and compassion at about 0.44
assertiveness and enthusiasm at about
0.47 and openness and intelligence about
0.35 so openness and intelligence seem
to be
somewhat maximally differentiated as far
as aspects go
so the average correlation between the
big five is r equals 0.22
and the correlation between the big two
is r equals 0.24
so that just gives you some idea of how
much segregation
and how much overlap there is between
the different aspects underneath the
trait level
let's see
so what i should really tell
you first i guess is how is how to
conceptualize iq
yeah this is a good one so
you want to follow this carefully so
that so that you
you you can explain it to yourself and
so that you can explain it to other
people so here let's say you want to
make an iq test
so this is what an iq test is the first
thing you might imagine that
is that
you have a huge library of questions and
there be questions that could be
formulated in language or some other
symbolic manner
often they don't have to be but often
and then they require
skill or knowledge to answer so here's
some typical questions and you could
generate multiple exemplars of questions
like this
what's 2 times 68 what's the capital of
georgia
how do you find how do you define
hypertrix anemia
um complete the pattern 2 4
8 16. remember these numbers
2 4 then you tell them back to me 6 12
15 14 18 20 22 you
tell them back to me that's a working
memory test by the way but working
memory is basically
indistinguishable from intelligence in
many many ways
so then you know another thing i might
have you do for example is i might show
you a pattern made out of
squares and then give you some blocks
and so that you could make
the pattern out of the blocks and then
time you to see how long it took you or
maybe
only give you a certain amount of time
and if you didn't do it then you either
pass or fail
i might show you some patterns this is
like a ravens progressive matrices test
which is
one of the most tests that is the most
accurate at assessing
nonverbal intelligence or fluid
intelligence so i might show you
six patterns six designs and
each design changes sorry eight designs
imagine a three by three array three
here three here
two here and a question mark and then
over here i'd show you a bunch of
options of patterns and one of the
patterns would complete the sequence and
usually you could calculate the sequence
going down
or across and and diagonally as well and
that looks
somewhat like a working memory test in
that usually the raven's progressive
matrices patterns
involve a couple of different variables
like it might be color
and shape or something like that and so
in order to complete the
the test you have to figure out how the
color is transforming and figure out how
the shape is transforming
or maybe in a more complex ravens
matrices question
it would be color shape
and position on the page or something
like that so you're increasing the
number of dimensions that have to be
attended to
simultaneously in order to solve the
problem
so so one of the things that's quite
interesting about the iq test it really
doesn't matter what the questions are
and so so anyway so imagine you have a
whole pile of these questions lying
around like a universal
pile a universal library of potential
questions that require
abstraction to solve and then you take a
random set of a hundred of those
and then you give that to a thousand
people and then you just
score some up there
you just sum up their scores
and then you rank order them in terms of
their performance
and that's iq it's as simple as that
now you could do some other things you
could correct it for the age of the
participant
now sometimes that's useful and
sometimes it's not
um but you could do that and generally
if you standardize the score and you
correct it for age then what you get is
an iq
score i would so actually the the
the total would just be an indicator of
general cognitive ability an iq score
would be
the indicator of general cognitive
ability corrected for age
and that's it that's all and so
here's some of the strange properties of
of
of that set of scores if you factor
analyze the data set you'll pull out one
factor
and a few little bitty factors after
that and that factor will be very
very highly correlated with the sum
so correlated at 0.9 0.92 0.93 like
really highly correlated far more highly
correlated than
most tests are
far more highly correlated than most
tests are reliable
now another thing that's very
interesting is you take another set of
100 questions
and you give them to the same thousand
people and then you re-rank
order the people and then you correlate
the rank orders you get what i'm saying
the correlation between the rank orders
will be like 0.95
so what it means is no matter which set
of 100 questions you take out of this
universal library of questions
people are going to score in the same
order that they scored when they did the
first hundred
questions and that means that iq is
extremely reliable
test retest reliability this is actually
an even
more stringent form of reliability which
is alternative form reliability
so that's all there is to iq
it's very simple
now why it is that the ability to do
well on one of those questions is highly
correlated with the ability to do all
the rest of them
that's something that nobody really
understands i think it has to do with
the human capacity to abstract like
we can abstract and we can manipulate
abstractions it's not obvious that
there's any other creature that can do
that
and it seems to be in some sense modular
anything that can be abstracted
and then manipulated draws on exactly
the same set of underlying skills
whatever those happen to be
now
you might say well so what which is a
perfectly reasonable thing to say and so
what
is if you then take that rank order
then let's say you take the same
thousand people 20 years later and you
rank order them in terms of how well
they're doing at their job you could
just use income say
as a marker there's other markers you
could use but for the sake of simplicity
let's say
income the correlation between their
original rank order and the rank order
of their performance will be something
around if you had a full sample of
intelligence be something around 0.5
which is 0.5 is a staggeringly high
correlation
so you know you'll hear that when you
hear people talk about effect sizes
you'll hear them say that
0.2 is a small effect size and point
three is a medium effect size and point
oh sorry
0.5 is a medium effect size and so forth
what you find out if you look at the
literature empirically is that point
effect sizes of 0.5 correlations of 0.5
are vanishingly rare in the social
sciences if you ever do a study
with a reasonable number of people with
a novel
measure and you're predicting something
with it if you get a correlation of 0.5
boy
you're jumping around the room because
that's only going to happen
like once in your life unless you're
measuring something that someone has
already measured
and you just don't know it and so it's
it's
fair it's a it's a reasonable to point
out that the correlation between iq
say and academic performance or the
correlation between iq
and long-term career success the size of
that correlation is bigger than the
correlation between virtually
two two of virtually any other things
that social scientists
have ever discovered and the thing about
it too is it's very straightforward you
know what
the procedure that i just told you
anyone can replicate that
you know you're not going to come up
with a universal library of questions
obviously
but you can use the internet as a
reasonable proxy
so not only is iq easy to understand
from a measurement perspective it's also
the tests are very very easy to
replicate and they're extremely powerful
predictors
now it turns out actually that iq
is correlated more strongly with how
rapidly you learn a task
than it is with your performance per se
so the correlation between
rate of learning of something novel and
iq can be as high as 0.6 or 0.7
which you know the other bit of that
would probably be taken up by something
like conscientiousness
or openness or negatively with emotional
stability
so you're picking up a tremendous amount
of the variation between
in people's performances with that
single measure and you can derive a
pretty decent
indicator of iq in 20 minutes which is
also pretty
frightening you know so
well so that's our cue does anybody have
any questions about that
yes
well you have to formulate them in
language
that's all yeah
now a lot of people have complained
about the idea of intelligence because
they don't like the idea
they don't really mind the idea so much
that there are smart people
but people really don't like the idea
that there are dumb people
and you know it's it's it's it's really
not reasonable from a logical
perspective to have one without the
other
and it's easy to see why people object
to that because
whatever term you use to refer to
the low end of the intelligence
distribution rapidly takes on a
pejorative
nature so and so what happens is the
culture cycles through various words
decade by decade trying to
describe the lower end of the
intelligence distribution
but all the words end up being
pejorative and so they're they're
changed decade after decade
but you and you can understand that
because
first of all there's great danger in
labeling someone unintelligent
perhaps period but certainly if there's
measurement error you know so if you're
labeled unintelligent let's say
and you're not that's going to be real
catastrophe so there's measurement error
problems
but then you know you have to think
about the problems of not
doing the measurement
so this is something i've thought about
for a long time so
let's say that i assessed your verbal iq
before you came to
the university of toronto forget
linguistic differences assume we could
control for that which is very difficult
at the university of toronto because
there's so many people
who have english as a second language
but forget about that for a minute
let's say i got a entire population
distribution
not only of the applicants from the
university of toronto but of the entire
population
and i said categorically that the bottom
thirty percent
of the people in that distribution would
not be able to graduate from the
university of toronto
am i doing them a favor by not letting
them apply
or am i harming them
well we know perfectly well i mean the
probability that there's anybody in this
room that has an iq
of less than 115 is pretty damn low and
if
if there is someone in the room whose
general intelligence level is at that
level
you can bloody well be sure they're
working like mad dogs in order to keep
up
and i'm not saying that all of you who
have to work like mad dogs to keep up
you know are are necessarily
lower than you might be in iq i'm just
saying that
because iq in part seems to be a measure
of something like processing speed or
rate of understanding or something like
that
if you're not in the upper echelons of
the distribution and you're tasked with
extraordinarily difficult
tasks that require abstraction and quick
learning the only way that you can
compensate for it is by
working to an incredible degree and you
can do that and that's also why
at the university of toronto we know
this perfectly well and it's true in
other educational institutions
conscientiousness is almost as good a
predictor of grades
as intelligence and that only makes
sense to me it's like who the hell is
going to get the good grades
the smart people who work hard and i
mean would it wouldn't be good if that
wasn't the case as far as i can tell
because
hopefully what you get when you get a
grade is an indicator of how
fast you are how well you know the
material and how much effort you've put
into learning it
something like that the relationship
between creativity and grades at the
university of toronto is zero by the way
once you control for iq
which is you know perhaps rather
appalling but
the problem is is that it's very
difficult to assess creative people
right because they're annoying creative
people do things in a new way
and the problem with trying to assess
whether or not someone has done some
something in a new way
is that you have to come up with a new
scheme of grading for that
and you can believe that's not going to
happen you know and then it's worse
because if you're a creative person and
you're graded by someone who isn't
creative
they're not going to think you're
creative they're just going to think
that you're wrong
and so and you might be because lots of
times if you're creative you're also
wrong because it's not that easy to come
up with a novel way of doing something
or a novel hypothesis
that actually is going to be an
improvement over the previous hypothesis
right most of the time you're off on a
tangent and it's an incorrect tangent
now various people have criticized the
idea of a single
intelligence and so they've made i guess
the most famous ones
probably in the last 15 years or 20
years of being
robert sternberg and martin gardner
martin gardner is not a scientist by the
way
at all um he claims
directly that he doesn't really care if
his intelligences can be measured
well that's not that helpful because if
you're working as a scientist
if what you're talking about can't be
measured then it doesn't exist
and you can even make a philosophical
case i think that if what you're talking
about can't be measured in any possible
way
that there's no sense in assuming that
it exists now gardner is posited
intelligence is like linguistic musical
logical mathematical spatial body
kinesthetic
intrapersonal and interpersonal um
one thing you might note is that we
already have a perfectly good word for
all of those
performance variability across all those
domains insofar as it actually exists
and that would be talent so there's no
reason to confuse the word talent with
the word intelligence
and the next thing that you might note
is that a lot of these so-called
intelligences are likely captured not so
much by intelligence but by variability
and personality traits
which we already understand and so to
throw a bunch of new terms in like
linguistic musical logical mathematical
spatial body kinesthetic
interpersonal and interpersonal all that
does is muddy the conceptual waters
it adds now there's a reason for that
the reason is fundamentally political
and the political reason is is that
um it is uncomfortable for people to
admit
that there might be something like
actual differences in ability that are
important and unerraticable
now i can understand why people would
have trouble with that
but consider the alternatives
we know part of the reason that you're
here and
will perhaps stay here and will perhaps
be successful
in so far as you can define success
along the dimension of career attainment
say
in your life as it unfolds from this
time onward is because you work hard
okay but we also know that part of the
reason that you're here is because
you're smart
now the question is what should you do
with that from an ethical perspective
exactly should you say no i'm no smarter
than anyone else
which means that maybe you're much more
hard working than everyone else so
you're still
you know denigrating the non-achieving
end of the distribution
or do you say i've been blessed by
something that's actually beyond my
control and
am privileged as a consequence of that
and then
decide what exactly that means in terms
of your responsibility
those are your choices but but to not
take into account the fact that
you've been blessed at at least one
level of analysis with a favorable role
of the of the randomness dice seems to
me to completely
misstate the nature of the causal
sequences that propel you into what's
essentially a position of privilege
so but that by denying that the
differences the innate differences in
people with regards to important
abilities all you do is attribute all
your success to
your own particular individual
controllable actions and
i mean i'm not saying that you don't
deserve credit for your work it's like
more power to you and all of that but
the idea that some people are smarter
than others
that's not an idea that's a fact
and it's an uncomfortable fact and the
fact that we won't deal with it
means that people suffer unnecessarily
so let's go back to those people in the
distribution i say the bottom 30 percent
of the distribution isn't going to
be able to get a degree at the
university of toronto
um unless they are they're capable of
working
to an insane level and even then likely
not
um
so let's say that you have a ability
blind admission process
it's random so everybody's name
is thrown into a hat and if they get
pulled out they get to go
do you think that you're doing the
people who are going to fail a service
or not you know now you can make a case
that you are
because it's likely that there'll be a
couple of individuals
in the bottom part of the distribution
who will make it through
partly because of measurement error
right because you're not going to
measure this perfectly
and partly because well people are
surprising and amazing creatures and you
never know exactly what any given one of
them is going to do
but you're going to torture a lot of
them to death at the same time
you know i've been struggling with this
because i've developed tests that help
employees employers decide who might be
competent
more competent than who when they're
hiring and that's partly dependent on
general cognitive ability and we think
based on the statistics
the relevant statistics that we can
improve the probability that a given
employee employer will hire an above
average worker in a cognitively complex
um for a cognitively complex job
position
from 50 50 to 75 25 or 80 20.
it's quite a lot but it's not obviously
there's still a
there's still a fair margin of error
there but
you know having half as many employees
below average is definitely going to be
of tremendous benefit to your company
and you might say well that's unfair
because there's going to be measurement
error too
and that's not the question the question
is it
is is it is it more unfair than to do it
any other way
well you could use interviews but tall
good-looking extroverted people
tend to do much better on interviews
than short ugly introverted people
especially if they're a little bit on
the disagreeable side as well because
agreeable people also do better in
interviews
so not only are they tremendously biased
in all of those dimensions they actually
don't predict performance in the long
run very well at all
so actually that means in the states
they're illegal you know
although companies lawyers haven't woken
up to this fact yet but
you're mandated by law in the united
states to use the most accurate
valid and reliable current means of
hiring available
and interviews are not that and neither
are letters of recommendation which are
pretty much as bad
they're not so much biased the letters
of recommendation they're just useless
because you know except insofar as if
you can't get
anyone to write you a letter of
recommendation at all well maybe that's
an indication
that you're very you're not very
socially skilled or that you don't have
a very good social network or whatever
so maybe as a really blunt indicator of
isolation
you could derive some information out of
letters of recommendation but
as far as valid indicators of future
performance they're just not valid at
all
it's partly why i hate writing them it's
they're they're
they're they're also illegal at least
they they are in the us
even though people don't understand that
yet but i know the law and i know the
validity statistics so
and what you're required to do
so then you might also ask so the so the
other selection
methods are also biased and
unreliable you could say well you could
hire someone based on their academic
history
but roughly that's an index of
intelligence and conscientiousness
anyways it's just not a very good one
especially because there's tremendous
variability between schools so
if you have a you know a gpa of 4.0
from school x and this person has a gpa
of 4.0 from school y
there's no reason at all to assume that
those are comparable
so you can use grades but that's full of
measurement error so that's not very
good either
so you could guess
that'll give you 50 50 in terms of your
probability of hiring someone who's
above average versus below average
but that doesn't seem to be a very
intelligent way of going about it
either because and here's here's
something to think about
so let's assume that there are 10 people
working
and inappropriate selection method
places an incompetent manager above them
so maybe the manager is less intelligent
than the workers that might be
one possibility or maybe the manager is
less creative than the workers are maybe
the manager is less conscientious or
whatever it doesn't matter some
dimension of competence is
not well matched with the demands of the
job well then
one of the questions is what exactly are
you doing to the manager
well you're basically setting them up to
fail and the tremendous number of
managers fail in the first two years of
their
of their promotion it's it's well above
50 percent
and so that's not so good for them but
then you're also
dooming the 10 people that they're
supervising to a kind of horrible per
you know perdition for the time it takes
for everyone to calculate that the
manager is actually failing and what
that means
generally is that the very highly
qualified people in the worker pool will
just leave because why would they put up
with that
so then you might think well is it
unethical to select properly or is it
ethical to select
randomly or exactly how should you solve
that problem
and the answer is well we do try to
solve it because we use selection
methods but we usually use ones that
aren't very accurate
it's funny too because i tried selling
accurate selection tests to corporations
for a very long period of time
and one of the things i learned is they
didn't want them
that was mind-boggling to me because the
economic utility in hiring people who
are competent compared to people who
aren't is so high it's absolutely
mind-boggling
because the difference in productivity
between people isn't even
it isn't normally distributed it's
paredo distributed some people are
staggeringly more productive than other
people so tilting your selection
criteria so that you pick from the more
productive end of the distribution means
incredibly powerful economic benefits
for your company
but um at least when i was doing this to
begin with human resources people who
were usually the ones evaluating the
tests
weren't necessarily the most competent
people in the corporate environment
which is something that hasn't changed
very much
they were very badly trained and they
believed that there were no differences
between people that couldn't be
eliminated with training
which is like yeah no no that's wrong as
anybody
if you have any sense at all and you
think about it for 15 or 20 seconds
you know that's the case you know i
don't know what it was like in your
school but in the school i went to which
was way the hell up in northern alberta
in the middle of no man's land
you know there was at least 15 percent
of the students i would say it was
probably higher
who were still functionally illiterate
by the time they hit grade 10
functional illiteracy being they had
never read an
entire book and that's way more common
than you think
like i don't know how common you think
that is but the stats basically indicate
there's as many people with iqs of 85
and lower as there are people with iqs
of 115 and higher
so and i already said that the minimum
iq level of anybody in this room is
likely to be something around 115.
so the person in this room who has the
lowest general cognitive ability is
smarter than 85 percent of the general
population
at 85 and lower which is there's just as
many people there as there is at 115 and
higher
at 85 and lower then you don't get
literacy
so people with iqs of 90 or less have a
difficult time
translating written words into action so
they can't really read instructions
so and that's like
ten percent of the populations fifteen
percent of the population actually
fifteen percent of the population and
it's so
you might say well no way it's like well
you don't get to have an
opinion on this by the way because the
science has already been done but i can
tell you one fact it's pretty unsettling
so
the united states army has been doing iq
testing on its recruits for
since before world war one they actually
did a lot of the research that
established iq tests and validated them
and indicated that they were reliable
and so forth and they had a variety of
reasons for doing that
um partly i guess they didn't want to
put incompetent people in charge of
deadly machinery which you know does
seem to be a reasonable
proposition i would say but what they
found
as a consequence of their hundreds
hundred years of testing was that
you couldn't teach anybody with an iq of
83 or lower anything at
all that would make them anything but an
obstacle to the um tasks that the armed
forces had to complete on a regular
basis
so that's 83 so now in the united states
it's actually
illegal to induct anyone into the armed
forces if they have an iq of 83 or lower
and that's more than 10 of the
population now you've got to think about
that
because what it means is that
approximately 10
percent of the population is
sufficiently
um has sufficiently low
general cognitive ability that
one of the complex enterprises that's
chronically most
desperate for manpower has decided that
there's no point in even trying
now that's a dismal outcome but
i don't know exactly what you're
supposed to do with that fact but
ignoring it doesn't seem to me to be the
right thing because it doesn't solve the
problem and this is going to become an
increasing
increasingly present
and and and
unavoidable unignorable problem because
you know already that's what's happening
in developed countries
less so in underdeveloped countries but
the gap between the rich and the poor is
is increasing so for for example almost
all of the
increases in wealth that have accrued to
people in the last 20 years have accrued
to people who are in the top one percent
of the distribution of wealth
and that's not going to stop by the way
and part of the reason
is is that cognitive power has become
even more valuable than it was
four years ago and the reason for that
is computers
basically because if you're really smart
and you're good with a computer
you're way ahead of someone who isn't
very smart and who doesn't know how to
use computers at all
and you're not just a little bit ahead
you're leaps and bounds ahead and worse
than that you're getting farther ahead
all the time
and the reason for that is that
computational power keeps increasing and
it increases
a lot it's doubling about every 18
months
so part of the problem that the human
race is going to have to face in the
next
30 years along with many other problems
is
what are you going to do with people who
have neither the cognitive ability
nor the conscientiousness to find
a niche in society that's actually
that that other people will value enough
to pay for
because that's really the question what
do you do
well the conservative answer to that is
well there's a job for everyone it's
like
no that's wrong there isn't and the
liberal answer is well everybody's the
same so it's just a matter of training
and that's also wrong they're both both
of those positions are
there the scientific research has
rendered them permanently outdated
well you know there is the possibility
of providing
a minimum income the the
the question what will that do is
completely unanswerable we have no idea
what it'll do
you know and i mean it might stop people
from
from starving to death although i
wouldn't say in north america
that's generally not a problem people
have anyways but
we don't know see i think of that i
think of human beings as pack animals
fundamentally you know
and i and i this is just
it's a metaphor in some sense i don't
think that people can be happy unless
they are
burdened down with something like a sled
dog is burdened down with something
you know you you have to have a
responsibilities they have to be
important responsibilities
you have to be sequenced in your time
you know most of the people i have in my
clinical
practice if they're not employed they
just fall apart and the conscientious
ones fall apart because they
eat themselves up with shame and and
guilt
and the unconscientious ones fall apart
because their sleep schedule goes all
over the place they don't eat regularly
regularly anymore they do all sorts of
impulsive things that are
counterproductive
and you know they just sort of spiral
into a pool of meaninglessness
so human beings are pretty social and
we're pretty altruistic
you know in in some weird manner and it
doesn't seem to me that people can live
a life
that's acceptable
if all they have is enforced leisure so
maybe that'll be wrong if you provided
people with a base salary
maybe people would figure out what to do
with their spare time but
um i doubt it
i don't think people are i think it's
very very difficult for people to
regulate themselves in the absence of a
certain minimum of
of social structuring and guidance i've
seen very very few people who can
conjure that up on their own and manage
it for
extensive periods of time i think i've
only met one person i would say in my
whole life who's actually managed that
and that particular person has a very
large array of talents and is extremely
intelligent
so
all right
so you might ask well what what
what exactly is intelligence and maybe
what exactly is the ability to abstract
and
i think it's something like this
the world is made out of the world is a
very very high resolution place
no matter how much you zoom into
something you can zoom in more
there's information that more and more
and more and more levels of detail and
then
also no matter how far you back away
from something
there's more and more and more levels of
detail so
you know you guys are composed of a
whole variety of subsystems
complex functioning subsystems all the
way down to the subatomic level
and then above your phenomenological
level of perception
your members of families your members of
cities your members of
provinces and and nationalities and
international organizations and
ecological
structures and so forth and so on and
all of that's characteristic of you
all the time and in every situation but
you don't deal with all that information
and you can't and so one of the things
that people seem to have learned how to
do is to abstract from that
and i'm not exactly sure what it means
to abstract but it seems to me that it
means something that's similar to
producing
um a low resolution representation like
a thumbnail
and so actually when i look at each of
you what i'm actually
seeing is a thumbnail of what you are
you know
first of all obviously i don't see the
other side of you that or
or either side for that matter i only
see you face on so in some sense it's a
two-dimensional
um thumbnail and then i have no idea
what's going on
in the subsystems that that constitute
you
at levels outside you know underneath
your mirror surface
that's a complex diagnostic problem for
example if there was something wrong
with you and
i can't see your families or except in
very
you know low resolution ways your
nationality or any of the systems that
you're
identified with and embedded in
so just looking at you is an act of
abstraction
you know and part of that thankfully is
done by the fact that our sensory
systems just aren't that good
so there's a whole bunch of things we
can't perceive and that
simplifies the problem now what we're
hoping is that i can
perceive enough of you at a given time
so that if i interact with you
i get what i want and you get what you
want roughly speaking it's something
like that
so what we hope is the model the
abstract model even of perception itself
is sufficiently accurate so that it's
sufficiently
it's a sufficiently unbiased sample of
the reality that it reflects so that if
i interact with it things work out the
way that i would like them to work out
but
there's lots of times when that doesn't
happen at all right it doesn't happen
when you're sick
the fact is that you're the resolution
of your sensory apparatus is a huge
impediment to figuring out why you might
be ill
you know and it doesn't help much either
when people are engaged in struggles
that go beyond the merely personal so
if we happen to be if i happen to be the
member of one ethnic group and you
happen to be the member of another and
there's strife between those two ethnic
groups then the fact that i can perceive
you at this level of resolution might
have very little to do with my ability
to solve that particular problem
now obviously people can abstract
you know part of that's just built into
us so that we abstract the phenomena
that we see
but then human beings i think in some
sense are capable of meta abstraction so
i think what happens is you can imagine
that
there's the phenomena in and of itself
whatever that is that complicated
multi-layer thing that's always in front
of you
and then there's your representation of
it which is what you perceive
which is already extracted to a
tremendous degree and limited to a
tremendous degree
and then there's abstractions of that
so what seemed what it seems to me to be
is that
language is a thumbnail of images that
are a thumbnail of the reality of things
it's something like that so it's a dual
compression so if i say cat to you
you'll what what the word cat does for
you is produce the image of a generic
cat which is already a kind of
abstraction and then
that's attached to your understanding in
some sense so that
you can you can generate the
understanding that would go along with
at least in part with perceiving or
interacting with a real cat
so in some sense what you're doing is
i'm compressing the information down to
a tremendously
low resolution thumbnail and i'm
throwing that at you and you decompress
it into a low resolution image and then
you decompress that into something
that's
roughly equivalent to reality that's
what you're doing
when you're reading a book for example
right because when you read the book you
can conjure up images of the places that
the author is talking about you conjure
up images of the characters themselves
so to such a degree that if you go to
see a movie that's made of your favorite
book you might be irritated because the
person in the movie looks nothing like
the person that you read about at least
as far as your imagination was concerned
now intelligence in general seems to be
whatever
underlies the ability to generate those
low resolution representations
to and to utilize them so that would
mean to manipulate them
in your own mind but also to communicate
them to others
a big part of intelligence is working
memory and working memory is
well while you're sitting there thinking
if you're thinking how many of you think
in words primarily as far as you're
concerned
so how many of you don't
think in images anybody images
well that's another possibility how many
of you think in words and images
okay okay so so okay well that's fine
you know the images are already a
representation and
in many ways the words are a
representation of the images
and so your ability to abstract and then
your ability to manipulate those
abstractions seems to be at the core of
whatever
intelligence is and that's what iq
purports to measure
um your working memory
so when you're if you sit there right
now um
so let's do this here is the sentence to
think about
okay now think about that sentence okay
so
the faculty that you're using to
represent that sentence
to yourself is working memory
and it's not very powerful you can't
contain very much in your working memory
seven digits is about the maximum now
people vary some people think that four
bits of information is actually the
limit to working memory some people
think it's closer to seven but it's not
very much that's why telephone numbers
tend to be seven digits long
so you can kind of easily remember seven
things which is not very many things
you know so part of what your
intelligence is is the breadth of that
working memory and then
the speed with which you can run
abstractions through it
so now you know i've put a little map
here up
so that the thing on the top left well
that's sort of a multi-dimensional
it's a schema of a multi-dimensional
reality and i
you know if you look at that what it is
it's a collection of dots or circles
arrayed in a variety of different arrays
my proposition is that you can represent
that array in a variety of different
ways i've called them object one
you can't see object two slide error
object three object four and object five
those are all low resolution
representations of the thing that's in
the top left hand corner and you can see
that
in some sense they capture something
important
they capture some important element of
the thing in the top left hand corner
but they don't capture all of it
now it might be that not capturing all
of it is a good idea because you don't
want to use any more information than
you have to and then
at the bottom well those are words or
semantic symbols of one form or another
and
they represent the representations
um i saw temple
grandin speak once i don't remember if i
told you about this but she's a very
famous
autistic researcher um she's quite
autistic and she's very fun to listen to
she's quite a good public speaker which
is quite remarkable
she's trying to figure out she thinks
that autistic people think like animals
and and she actually works with animals
and she seems to be very good at
understanding them
she believes that what things that
frighten her are the same thing that
frightens animals and for the same
reasons and so
her proposition for example is that if i
say the word
church all of you people are going to
have
what you might describe as a schematic
abstraction like a hero glyph that's
more or less representative of the class
of churches and so
or maybe i can say house kids are good
at this you see this house it's like
it's got a little rectangle on the top
and it's got a
kind of a square on the bottom it's got
a door and two windows and the windows
have crosses in them and there's always
a chimney on the top with smoke coming
out
which i think is quite remarkable
because you actually don't see that many
houses now that have chimneys with smoke
coming out but still that's the
canonical image for a child temple
grandin's
claim was that she cannot see
house she can only see a house
and so if you say to her something like
house then what comes to mind is a
particular house that she's actually
experienced she can't
take the next level of abstraction past
that which seems to be
something like a deficit in generating
like a hieroglyphic
image one one of the ways to think about
children's drawings you know how they
draw people with sticks
and circles you know you think oh that's
so primitive it's like no it's not it's
unbelievably sophisticated because
those aren't pictures they're
hieroglyphics and the child
automatically produces them and that's a
proto-linguistic development
so some autistic kids can draw like
leonardo da vinci with no training
whatsoever
and that's partly because they don't use
hieroglyphics and that means that they
don't really conceptualize the thing
they're looking at
as an abstraction they see nothing but
detail
and if you're training yourself to be a
visual artist you have to stop
looking at the abstraction and you have
to start looking at the thing
and that's very unsettling so if you
take your hand for example
and you look at it and you snap it out
of hand representation
when you do that property it all of a
sudden looks like some kind of like
octopus claw
it's a very bizarre looking thing and as
soon as you see it that way you can draw
it
but as long as you're seeing it like a
hand you're going to put you know
a balloon with four balloons on it or
something like that and that's going to
be the hand
so all right
this guy's name is john carroll carol's
a real scientist
um he looked at
the structure of iq for a very long
period of time wrote a very thick book
on it
which nobody likes to read because it's
almost entirely technical
so it's really more of a reference book
but what
what carol hypothesized and i think his
hypothesis is as close to
state of the art as as any is that
there's a stratum three level which is
fluid intelligence
g and it's the main factor that unites
all these other tests and then that
stratum one you get fluid intelligence
crystallized intelligence verbal
intelligence i don't remember what the
rest of them stand for and then
each of those can be sub divided into
specific tests and each of the tests can
be
subdivided into somewhat particularized
individual cognitive abilities now
they're not that individual because
there's a single factor that accounts
for most of the variability in the
performance
so
in a sense what this theory says is that
the intelligence is sum up to one
intelligence and that seems to be
essentially correct
this although you can't see it very well
um
if you look at g there on the left
the lines leading to the first or i
think that's the second strata the next
strata anyways
show you the correlation between g and
each of the individual intelligences and
what you see is the correlation between
g and fluid intelligence is 0.94 which
is such a tight correlation that it
might as well just be the thing itself
between g and
and crystallized intelligence is 0.85
all of the first order correlations
there are above 0.8
that's exactly and then at the far right
you get
concepts that you might think about as
particularized and
so those include concept formation
analysis
and synthesis number series number
matrices spatial relations picture
recognition
block rotation visual matching decision
speed
block rotation crossout
visual and auditory learning memory for
name sound blending incomplete word that
would be incomplete word completion
sound patterns auditory attention etc
etc and
you can think of those each as
individual tests in that you could make
a test that theoretically only
individually assessed that thing but you
couldn't help but be testing all sorts
of other things at the same time because
that
they're not actually individual one of
the things you will learn
is that there are neuropsychological
tests
and the neuropsychologists like to think
that iq
is something that's primitive and that
they've already
what would you say advanced past and so
they have specific
prefrontal tests say that hypothetically
assess specific
prefrontal abilities and then they'll
note that if you take a single test of
prefrontal ability and correlate it with
iq it'll only correlate at about 0.3 or
0.4
and then they'll assume because it only
correlates that low that it's measuring
something other than what iq is
measuring
but really what happens is that it's
just not a very good iq test and the
reason that the correlation is so low is
because of measurement error so if you
gave the same test
to the same person 20 times and then you
varied the test so there were 30
variants of it
you gave those all to the same person 20
times then what would come out would be
a score that would be much more highly
correlated with iq
and probably indistinguishable from it
and so you'll learn from
neuropsychologists that there's such a
thing as prefrontal ability and that's
associated with executive control
and that's associated with
self-regulation which would be control
over your impulses
and as far as i can tell that's all
completely wrong
and it took me like ten years to figure
that out because i was taught that it
was right and it wasn't until i
plowed through it painfully to and
understood that there was no evidence
for that so i can tell you how that
works so for example
we gave a neuropsych battery that
consisted of dorsolateral prefrontal
tests to 3000
people it was a 90 minute battery so it
was exhaustive
and when we factor analyzed it when
there was only about 200 participants we
got four factors
but then when we factor analyzed it
after we had three thousand participants
we got two factors
and one was one on which almost all the
tests loaded and it was undoubtedly
fluid intelligence
so but it's worse than that you know
because you hear about how the
prefrontal cortex regulates behavior
well here's a problem with that
what's the correlation between iq and
conscientiousness
zero roughly speaking it's probably a
little
off zero although it might not be and
you know that because the dimensions of
the big five are roughly orthogonal i
showed you at the beginning of this that
each
trait of the big five traits is
correlated with the other trait on an
average of about 0.2 now why that is
it's probably because of something like
um
what would you call it's probably a halo
effect if you tend to rate yourself as
positive on one trait more conscientious
more agreeable more emotionally stable
you're going to tend to rate yourself as
more positive on the other traits
so that would artificially inflate their
correlation that's one way of looking at
it
anyways weirdly enough the correlation
between conscientiousness and iq
is essentially zero now that's a big
problem isn't it because
it's unconscientious people that seem to
be behaviorally dysregulated
right they can't stick to a task they
they they jump about they're they're not
on track
they appear impulsive although we don't
know how to define impulsive by the way
but your heel psychologists use that all
the time
it's like well if prefrontal ability
regulates behavior how come the
correlation between
intelligence and other forms of
executive control are correlated with
conscientiousness at zero
right zero is a very bad number when
you're testing out a hypothesis
so and you know if you think about it it
has to be that way and the reason it has
to be that way is this
like so if you're dreaming you're going
to just lay there and dream
but your eyes are going to move back and
forth now you might say why aren't you
running around
acting out your dreams while you're
dreaming and the answer to that is
there's a little
switch in your head roughly speaking
that shuts off
your motor apparatus when you're
dreaming and so what happens is
you can't run around and act out all
your dreams because you're
paralyzed and sometimes people wake up
in that state
it's called sleep paralysis they wake up
they're sort of half awake and they
can't move and then they often
hallucinate all sorts of weird things
and thinks
aliens have come and abducted them and
various peculiarities but
if you take a cat and you take out that
little switch then the cat will run
around while it's dreaming until it runs
into something which is the problem
with running around acting out your
dreams
so what does that allow one to conclude
well if you couldn't abstract away from
your behavior
you couldn't think right because what
thinking means is to represent
an alternative world or maybe just a
tiny little fraction of the world
whatever
to represent it abstractly to manipulate
it around
but not to simultaneously act it out
then it wouldn't be abstracting at all
it would be fiddling about with the
world through trial and error
so you have to be able to pull what you
think about out of your body
so to speak play with it and then
implement it back in now it looks
maybe like the ability to implement a
plan is associated with
conscientiousness but we don't
understand that that would be
industriousness
and we don't know a bloody thing about
industriousness like it's just a black
hole
but the idea that it's your ability to
think that allows you to regulate your
behavior strikes well
there's no evidence for it there's no
evidence for it
smart people are not necessarily better
at regulating their behavior
so because for you can have a very
unconscientious smart person
and you i see them in my clinical
practice now and then they come and say
well i'm really smart and here's the
evidence but i'm doing very badly in
everything
they're underachievers roughly speaking
you know so
they can't implement their thoughts not
in any stable manner
so the fact that they're smart
you know on average across their life
smart people are healthier mentally and
physically than people who aren't as
smart but the reason for that isn't
because
their intelligence allows them to
regulate their health the reason for
that is because their intelligence
allows them
roughly speaking to succeed so they're
higher up in the dominance hierarchy
and if you're higher up in the dominance
harkey then your life isn't stressful
and you don't get sick as often
but that doesn't indicate that there's a
direct control between your intelligence
and your behavioral output
there's very little evidence for that
well i think there's no evidence for it
so that's rather shocking so
you know to me that just wiped out a
whole a whole
substrate of psychological theorizing
and it's i'm sure
how many of you have come up against the
proposition that prefrontal ability was
associated with behavioral control
yeah yeah well it isn't
so you know not any more than i first of
all it's not differentiable from iq
regardless of what the
neuropsychologists say because they
don't know anything about psychometrics
generally and they don't like iq because
if they studied iq then what they'd find
is all the things that they're studying
are basically variants of iq
and that would suck because other people
have already figured out iq
and then there's the big problem which
is well
variation in prefrontal ability which is
equivalent to variation in iq
isn't correlated with behavioral control
it's a really big
problem so and so i would like to say
well what is correlated with behavioral
control and then but the problem with
that is well i don't know what you mean
by behavioral control i don't know how
you're going to measure it
and if you do measure it the probability
that you're going to come up with
something like conscientiousness is
pretty much 100
so all right
let's see
yes effect sizes this is from a very
important paper by a guy named hemphill
called interpreting the magnitudes of
correlation coefficients from the
american psychologist number 58.
what hemphill did was look at a whole he
didn't guess it how big
an effect size had to be for it to be a
big effect size what he did was go into
the literature and study a whole bunch
of papers
and then empirically rank the effect
sizes so that would be the standard
deviation
difference or the correlation or the r
squared you can convert those
and then decide you know what proportion
of papers had which
effect size and decide that well you
could empirically rank them and then
you'd know
how big your effect size was and what he
found was that
um about three percent of social science
studies showed a
correlation coefficient of 0.5 or above
and that's about the correlation between
iq and
and general life success in relatively
complex
conditions point three five to point
five
only about one in four papers to one in
ten
an hour 0.15 to 0.35 25 to 57
percent of papers and then r of less
than 0.15 was about a quarter of papers
so what that means is the ability of iq
to predict whatever it is that you want
to predict with it is
way the hell up in the in the rare
rare what would you call it
well it's up in the stratosphere with
regards to effect power
okay so what does it mean practically
speaking
this is from a company called the
wonderlic company
in the wonderlic wonderlic sells iq
tests to businesses now it's actually
illegal for
businesses to use iq tests in the united
states
so actually it's illegal to do anything
to hire employ employees in the united
states as it turns out because
you have to use a test you have to use
the test that's the most
valid and reliable available that
doesn't produce any ethnic or gender
differences
well there's no tests like that so it's
illegal it's also so it's illegal to use
interviews it's illegal to use letters
of reference it's illegal to use ability
tests
you might be able to use
conscientiousness tests
because conscientiousness tests do seem
to be completely
free of
not exactly because older people are
more conscientious than younger people
so that's also a problem so
anyways wonderlic it's a good company it
makes really
it's iq tests are genuine tests but they
are iq tests
and people do use them in business even
though they're not supposed to but
so but what they've done over over a
long period of using the test is to come
up with approximations for
different forms of employment
opportunities so
how smart do you have to be in order to
be
placed in a given occupation with a
reasonable probability of success so we
can tell you here so
um let's see is that we got it exactly
the right place
okay so if you have iqs of 116 to 130
that's pretty much you guys although i
would suspect there's a fair chunk of
you that have an iq of over 130
because 130 makes you 115 makes you
15 130 makes you about 98 percentile
145 makes you 99th percentile 160 makes
you 99.9
percentile something else to think about
percentiles are strange things because
you might say
well there's no difference between
someone who scores 95th percentile on an
iq test and 99th percentile because it's
only four percentiles different but
that's not four percentages
the person who scores 95 is one in 20.
the person who scores 99 is
100 the person who scores 99.9
is one in a so thousand you might think
well it doesn't matter because as you
you know once you get to a certain
degree of smart that's smart enough and
now
that's wrong in fact it's it's probably
radically wrong
in that the differences between people
actually increase as you go up the iq
scale
so and that's because performance isn't
distributed in a normal distribution
it's distributed in a pareto
distribution such that
almost no one does anything and a very
small number of people do everything
so which is also a very dismal fact okay
so anyways if you're in the upper
echelons of the of the cognitive
distribution
so
from 116 to 130 you could be an attorney
a research analyst an editor an
advertising manager a chemist
engineer an executive a manager a trait
manager trainee a systems analyst or an
auditor from 115 to 110 110 to 115
so that's that'd be in the upper half of
a high school graduating class roughly
speaking
upper quarter copywriter accountant
manager
supervisor sales manager sales man
programmer analyst teacher adjuster
general manager purchasing agent
registered nurse
sales account executive 108 203
administrative assistant store manager
bookkeeper credit clerk drafter designer
lab tester
secretary accounting clerk medical debt
collection computer operator
customer service rep automotive salesman
clerk and typist
102 to 100 so that's pretty much right
at the mean
dispatcher general office dispatcher
police patrol officer receptionist
cashier general clerical work inside
sales clerk meter reader
printer teller data entry or an
electrical helper
for iq from 95 to 98 machinist
quality control checker claims clerk
driver delivery man security guard
unskilled labor maintenance machine
operator arc welder
mechanic medical dental assistant from
87 to 93
messenger factory production assembler
food service
worker nurses aid warehouseman custodian
janitor material handler
and packer and then
that's it
so you see that things are getting
pretty damn dismal for the people who
are
have an iq of 85 and below so
now
what's the difference between intellect
and openness proper
well one difference is that men seem to
be higher in intellect
the trait and women seem to be higher in
openness and openness seems to be
associated with verbal intelligence
and with imagination and with fantasy
and with aesthetic experience and it
seems to go along with the fact that
women read more fiction than men
so men read non-fiction roughly speaking
and women read fiction you know it's
obviously there's a lot of overlap but
fundamentally that seems to be how it
distributes maybe that's also partly
because women are more agreeable and so
they're more interested in human
relations and characters and
you know that's the central that's the
central theme of fiction
um people who are high in openness think
divergently
here we can do a quick little divergent
thinking test so why don't we do that
take out a piece of paper in a pen
and or or you can type on your computer
i don't care you can scratch it onto the
desk for all i care
it's law but get out a piece of paper
something you can write on and we'll do
this so
um i'll only give you a minute since
you're all so fast
then we only have six minutes left so
write down as many uses as you can think
of for a brick
you have one minute
so
okay that's all the time you get okay so
the first question is
i'm just going to ask you i'm going to
point at you and you can answer how many
how many
uses did you come up with
thirteen five
eight you two it's okay eight
that's all right seven
seven okay did anybody come up with more
than thirteen
how many fourteen did anybody come up
with more than fourteen
okay so you two are the most
idiationally fluent
people in the class and fluency is a
matter of the
rapidity with which you can generate
exemplars from a category
so one of the things that we might ask
just as much would be how many words can
you write that begin with the letter s
in a minute
and they'll be you wouldn't believe the
bloody range of that there'll be people
who'll be people who get six and
there'll be people who get fifty
you know so ideational fluency is
actually a pretty decent predictor of
creative ability
now you know that's not a great test
right because it was very short and
i do that multiple times with multiple
time durations and just different
exemplars and some across that but
the correlation between aviation fluency
and long-term creative achievement is
about 0.3
that's pretty major okay so let's hear a
use for a brick
how about you
oh you could draw on the sidewalk with a
brick how about you
a paperweight how many people got
paperweight yes that's a low creative
response
now why that doesn't mean that all your
responses are but it's a technical
definition
right so here's what makes a response
low creative
everyone has it now it's a perfectly
reasonable response
but for it to be creative virtually by
definition it has to be
a low probability response that actually
makes sense
so draw on sidewalk is is is is
a more low probability response somebody
got a weird use for a brick
ground into dust and used
okay okay all right anybody else have
that
they ground their brick into dust for
something no
yes you could kill someone with a brick
anybody have that
yes low agreeableness low creativity
yeah yeah okay so anybody else go to
like a peculiar one for a brick yeah
yeah anybody else have that okay so you
know it's
kind of a lousy musical instrument but
in a pinch it would work
yeah well that's a good one
first of all you can kill it and then
you can drown it
yeah yeah so the way you would score
this by the way it's quite straight
it's not that straightforward actually
first of all you count the number of
responses and you get rid of ones that
are
um repetitive and then you also get
usually a couple of people to throw at
once that are just
like they're neither original nor
practical the best
responses are original and practical now
there's a bit of a judgment call there
you know what i mean
but if you get a number of people to do
the rating you can get pretty decent
integrated reliability
and so then you score originality and
the way you score originality is
merely by summing like listing all the
responses
and then calculating how probable or
frequent the responses are and the more
infrequent responses you get a higher
score for
so it's def it's basically a population
sample so and those things actually work
those those tests just so you know now
i'll stop with this this is a this is a
a measure that i derived with one of my
students when i worked in boston her
name was shelly carson and
this thing has actually become one of
the standard measures of creativity
in the creativity literature which is
quite fun and
it's a creative achievement
questionnaire so what i gave you just
now was a creativity test
it's one of many creativity tests but it
wasn't a creative achievement test
because
you can generate uses for a brick
without running out and becoming a brick
entrepreneur you know
so there's a difference between being
able to think divergently and with loose
associations and then also
being able to put that into practice so
you achieve something and so here's some
levels of achievement so there's the
scientific discovery domain
i do not have training or recognized
ability in this field i often think
about ways that scientific problems
could be solved
i have won a prize at a science fair or
other local competition
i've received a scholarship based on my
work in science or medicine
i've been author or core author of a
study published in the scientific
journal
i've won a national prize i've received
a grant my work has been cited by other
scientists in national publications
okay and then the same thing for say
theater film and culinary arts
zero is i do not have training or
recognized ability and
theater and film number seven is my
theatrical work has been recognized in
the national publication
for culinary arts i do not have training
or experience
and the highest one is my recipes have
been published nationally
okay so
there's 13 different domains
and that's the distribution it's not
normally distributed
so what you see there actually it's not
quite right because the
the median answers about 66 percent of
the respondents to the creative
achievement questionnaire have a median
score of zero
right zero they do not have training or
talent in any of the 13 areas and then
there's some
people who are way out on the right hand
distribution
because you can imagine that once you
have national exposure in one magazine
as a writer the probability that you're
going to get national exposure again for
your second novel starts to go up pretty
damn high right
and so you get this terrible step down
function so that almost everybody
aggregates at nothing and then a few
people
are way out in the distribution and they
just get everything and there's actually
a law
it's called the matthew principle that
economists use and it's from a statement
in the new testament
from matthew and it's a statement where
christ says
from those who have to those who have
everything more will be given and from
those who have nothing everything will
be taken away
and that seems to be how creative
resources are distributed in the
population
and to a large degree that's dependent
on intelligence
openness and conscientiousness
so you can understand why
none of that's very popular with people
since you're all smart and conscientious
though it's going to work out well for
you
see you on tuesday
i'm going to post your midterm marks
what we're going to do after that with
regards to this strike i don't
i can't i don't know yet